how can we trust the ccp to care for and
protect our athletes the answer is we
can't we shouldn't
joining me now is mike pompeo former
secretary of state fox news contributor
mr secretary these olympics are poised
to be a massive pr coup
for president xi
and yet we're plowing right ahead
good evening laura great to be with you
look i've been calling for us not to let
our athletes go to beijing for a long
time now
i really regret that the leadership in
the united states and the ioc has failed
these athletes i love the olympics like
anybody my mother took me to the la
olympics i saw carl lewis run we were
sitting in some really high up seats at
the la coliseum i love this event
but your points well taken we shouldn't
prop up xi jinping this will become
known as the genocide olympics what's
taking place in western china is nothing
short of genocide we shouldn't forget
too this virus that you were talking
about at the beginning your show came
from the wuhan institute of virology
almost certainly that is this virus was
forced around the world
and then second not only are we propping
up one of the greatest human rights
violating leaders in all of recorded
history but we're putting our athletes
in a very difficult place imagine one of
them wants to say something about
tiananmen square or they want to talk
about the wuhan institute of virology i
promise you the chance of them getting
their exit visa will be low
and those athletes should all know too
that beijing is the most surveilled city
in the world whether it's their cell
phones or their ipads or whatever it is
or something they're saying to someone
else you can bet that the chinese
communist party will be able to track
everything they do
every place they go and everything they
say and they will record it will be used
for chinese communist party purposes for
time ongoing
now just days ago
this was a little notice story in the
washington post
it revealed that china was mining for
social media data
on westerners a post review of bidding
documents and contracts for over 300
chinese government projects since the
beginning of 2020 include orders for
software designed to collect data on
foreign targets from sources such as
twitter facebook and other western
social media i guess i'm in trouble mr
secretary
asked me if i care um no one's covered
this except this one piece uh thankfully
in the washington post
you know i hadn't seen the most recent
reporting but i certainly know precisely
what it is they're talking about it was
on your show goodness might have been as
much as a year ago when we first talked
to her more than a year ago when we
first talked about the risk from tick
tock right the fact that the chinese
were surveilling every data set and
surveilling kids here in the united
states who were using tick tock they
there there is no such thing as a
private entity there's no such thing as
private information this is all owned by
the chinese communist party it's all
controlled by the chinese communist
party will all be used for the purposes
of xi xingping and we have seen this the
person who doesn't care about basic
dignity for any human being he's
throwing reporters in jail in hong kong
he's taking the uyghurs in the west and
uh entering them and things that look
very much like what was taking place in
germany in the 1930s uh and we of course
have spoken about this virus that has
now killed millions of people across the
world uh this all came from the chinese
communist party uh they should be held
accountable for each of these things and
they should not be permitted to benefit
from the glory of the olympic movement i
mean it the fact that we never got
unique access into that wuhan lab we
were never able to examine the
original documents the
investigation to who patient zero was
and yet
a year plus later almost just a year
exactly later
oh it's just like applaud thank you sir
may i have another and he's going to be
sitting there in all his splendor in the
stadium
bragging that they were able to control
covid and their country of course by
welding people into their apartments and
we're and we're oh we're not sending
diplomats there though mr secretary
that'll show them does that make a
difference in the end that we're not
sending diplomats there
not a bit xingping doesn't care he's
going to get a chance to stand on the
world stage he'll be carried by american
media all across the world in global
media on the opening night of the games
and there he'll sit
talking to the world using chinese
propaganda tools all across the world
talking about this great democracy of
china and what a wonderful nation it is
uh this is this is the debacle
it shows you that the ioc itself is
disconnected from the central things
that matter now mr secretary you've been
an incredible leader and a voice on this
and we thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else